Some have called you China's [music]
Nostradamist. You had three famous
predictions in 2024 that Trump would get
elected, that he would start a war with
Iran, and that he would lose a war with
Iran. Iran clearly has the strateic
advantage. I think the next step in the
escalation ladder is that Trump will
send in ground [music] forces.
>> Nikki Haley was key to your prediction
about Iran. You said Trump would pick
her as his running mate, but he didn't
pick her. I think that the problem with
education is that it focuses too much on
facts, too much on rigor, and not enough
on facts. Do you hear yourself? Does
China [music] control what you say? Now,
your critics might say they're using you
as a propagandist.
>> It is possible I'm a useful idiot. And I
suspect that there are many entities
around the world who would like to
amplify my message, including the
Chinese government.
>> Hold on. Hold on. You don't call
yourself Professor Giang on your YouTube
channel?
>> I do now, but when I first started out,
if you go way back to my ear,
>> doesn't matter. When you first started
out, you do call yourself Professor Gag
and you're not a professor. [music] What
is your big prediction now for 2026?
We'll see what happens. We can test it
out at the end of the year.
>> Back in 2024, Chinese Canadian educator
Jiang posted a video on his YouTube
channel, Predictive History, where he
laid out three big predictions. Donald
Trump would win the 2024 election. The
US would then go to war with Iran and
ultimately the US would lose that war.
Since then, the self-styled professor
who says he uses game theory to analyze
the past and predict future geopolitical
events has become an internet sensation
and has even been dubbed China's
Nostradamus. But he's also faced some
criticisms over his predictions and many
would say pretty out there conspiracy
theories. Two out of three of Jiang's
big predictions have come true. But how
much of that is his own geopolitical
foresight? And how much of it simply
comes down to luck? How much does the
Chinese government control or even
influence what he says, what he
predicts? I decided to not just speak to
Chin Jang aka Professor Jiang about Iran
and the state of the world, but also to
challenge him a bit. Here's our
interview.
Chin Jiang, thank you so much for
joining me on Zateo. Um, you have said
you use game theory to predict future
geopolitical events. For those who have
never heard of game theory, please do
explain what it is and how it helps you
explain what's happening with Donald
Trump and with Iran in particular.
>> Right. So game theory applied to
geopolitics means that we see each
individual nation state as a player in a
zero sum game to maximize um its uh
individual interests. And so each player
would have its own characteristics, its
own strengths and it would adopt a OMA
strategy in order to win the zero sum
game. So how does that apply in the
Middle East right now?
>> Right. So um United States is attacking
Iran and these two nation states have
different strengths and weaknesses. So
America has um the world's greatest
military. It has a supremacy. It it has
tremendous technology. um and has
unlimited funding. And so Iran is
adopting an asymmetrical strategy of um
holding the global economy hostage.
Meaning that rather than attacking the
United States directly, which it cannot
defeat directly, it is instead um
controlling humus which is strangling
the global economy and it's attacking
the GCC nations um the infrastructure of
the GCC nations in order to force Trump
into the negotiating table. So that is
the atmical warfare of Iran.
>> Uh you've also predicted that the US you
had three famous predictions in 2024
that Trump would get elected, that he
would start a war with Iran, and that he
would lose a war with Iran. Based on
what you've seen over the past month, do
you still stand by that prediction?
>> Yes, I do. Um I think that after a
month, I think that um Iran clearly has
the strateic advantage. And what I mean
by that is that Iran is very clearly
able to articulate its uh military
objectives and it has a very clear
strategy of how to obtain these military
objectives and it is working uh very
hard and very meticulously to obtain
these objectives. This is a complete
opposite of America where Trump has
failed to articulate an end goal. Um,
and right now it seems that the
administration, the Trump
administration,
um, is unable to articulate both a
strategy and a purpose to the American
public, which is causing, um, most
Americans to not support this war. It's
also causing low uh, soldier morale
among the American forces.
>> What do you think happens next if slash
when Iran wins?
>> Right. So um even though Iran has the
advantage right now, we still have to
remember that America is the world's
greatest empire. It has a lot of
resources. It has a lot of uh firepower
still not used. So um um I think the
next step in the escalation ladder is
that Trump will send in ground forces.
So over 5,000 Marines uh and soldiers
have been dispatched to the Middle East.
This is already on top of the 50,000
American soldiers already stationed in
the Middle East and most military
analysts expect that um uh the Americans
will launch an amphibious assault in
order to control the sh of hummus. Now
there are several options available to
Americans um in order to control the
shamoose. Uh the first option is to
control K island which is the oil depart
of the Iranians. 90% of uh Iranians oil
exports um depart from Kark Island. Then
you have Kasim Island which is opposite
the um sh of Homus and then there's a
naval base uh further down the
coastline. And so these are the three
options uh that the Americans have and
it is unclear which option the Americans
will ultimately choose. Um but given the
track record of the Marines, we can
expect uh the Marines to have an early
success. The problem with the strategy
and the problem with America's overall
strategy is what happens next? How do
you maintain control over the territory
that you've claimed? The reality is that
the Iranians have been preparing this
battle for about 20 years. They
developed this um very effective
asymmetrical warfare strategy of using
drones and ballistic missiles from afar
uh hidden in underground bases to um uh
hit and strike American assets around
the Middle East. This is almost like
guerrilla warfare and historically um a
imperial power has had great
difficulties in containing guerrilla
warfare. So, unfortunately, the uh
Americans don't have a long-term
strategy of how to win this war. Trump
is still hoping for a quick strike, a
knockout punch. Um, and he believes that
the American Marines can deliver this
knock-off punch.
>> You uh have made a lot of predictions.
Um, some have called you China's
Nostradamus. How would you respond to
those who say, "Sure, you guessed that
Trump would win in 2024 and he'd go to
war with Iran." But that wasn't based on
geopolitical insights or game theory. Uh
people who follow American politics or
world politics could have guessed that.
I think I and many others were warning
that Trump could win in 2024 and that he
would escalate with Iran as he did in
his first term when he killed Hassim
Sullemani.
>> Right. So, I think that if you've been
following the news very closely, um then
it was actually pretty straightforward
to make these three predictions, right?
Because in Trump's first term, as you
mentioned, uh Trump did have a history
of escalating conflict with Iran. Um so,
um the biggest um escalation was when
Trump ordered the assassination of Kasam
Kasam Salmani. And quite frankly, uh,
America in Iran should have gone to war,
uh, during that that time. But because
of deescalation efforts on both sides,
we prevented World War II during that
time. But um, Trump was under tremendous
pressure from his allies and uh, from
his donors to start a conflict in the
Middle East. So if Trump had um had won
a second term, then he would have
started the conflict. I was pretty
confident that he would start the
conflict if he had won in 2020. U, but
uh, fortunately he lost. And so that
question then was what is the likelihood
that he would get a second term? Would
he win in 2024? And then as I watched
the news, it seemed um pretty obvious to
me that the Democrats um were hopeless
that they didn't that that they were not
delivering on the promises that um there
were a lot of issues. Uh for example,
what was happening in Gaza, the war in
Ukraine that was making um American
voters
um disillusion with the democratic um
establishment. Um, and so I thought that
Trump would have very good chance of
winning 2324. And if he if he won 20 24,
I think there's a very strong like
likelihood that he would attack Iran.
And so all three predictions have panned
out. Just on your predictions, I just
want to be clear here. Nikki Haley was
key to your prediction about Iran. You
said Trump would pick her as his running
mate and as vice president. She would
pressure Trump into war with Iran. She's
a notorious hawk. Uh, but he didn't pick
her. and his current vice president JD
Vance is widely seen as a skeptic of
this war. So you admit you got that
wrong?
>> Yes, absolutely. So um um so I was
thinking of what Trump's electoral
strategy would be in 2024. And I think
that if he picked Nikki Haley, this
would be a boost to his uh campaign
because Nikki Haley would be very
popular among neocons in Washington DC.
She would also be very popular among
suburban white women. Uh that was key to
Biden's victory in 2020. Um, so I made
the prediction that uh he would pick
Nikki Hely, but at the same time um I
was not completely sure about it um
because I also felt that JD Vance also
had a good opportunity to be um selected
and I also said during my lecture u
making the prediction that Nikki Haley
would be his running mate that depending
on whether or not he picked Nikki Haley
or JD Vance this would determine how we
can um foresee or understand Trump's
second term.
And so um if he had picked Nikki Hilly
then he would have been completely full
he would he would have been fully
committed into the neocon project of
regime change throughout the Middle East
of supporting Israel of establishing
American imperial power throughout the
world. Um he didn't pick Nikki Hilly
instead he picked the complete opposite
who is Vance who has who is America
first who has always been skeptical of
American uh imperial over over
overreach. But not only that, he also
picked Telsey Gabbard to be his director
of national intelligence. And so these
are the two major skeptics of this war
in the Middle East. And what I will say
about picking these two individuals is
that it shows that Trump has an off-ramp
strategy where if this if this war goes
sideways and and the American public is
up in arms and uh he's lo he's losing in
the polls then Trump may decide to pivot
back to America first and have JD Vance
and Ty Gabbard elevated in the
administration over individuals such as
Marco Rubio and Peter Hexv. Um so that
yeah
>> I suspect he will blame Pete Hexith if
all of this goes sideways as it is. Um
where does China fall into all of this?
You're a Chinese Can Canadian. You're
based in Beijing. Uh China clearly
stands to gain from a failed US war with
Iran. Uh how many how much of your views
are reflective of China's views? The
Chinese government's views, the CCP's
views.
>> Right. So the official Chinese um
Communist Party line is that China is
committed to global peace and to global
trade that benefits all. Um he China
wants a win-win globalized system in
which people are trading peacefully and
which everyone is committed to world
peace. And so China has come out vocally
criticizing both Iran and the United
States. United States for starting this
war but also Iran for attacking uh the
GCC energy infrastructure. Remember that
um uh China relies heavily on Qatar uh
liqufied natural gas as as is the case
with other countries in Europe. Um so
China looks at what's happening in the
Middle East and China I think is working
very hard diplomatically to come to an
agreement. Unfortunately, right now,
China doesn't have much uh leverage over
either United States or Iran. In fact,
many um analysts believe that this war
was started in part to um economically
strangle uh China because China depends
on a lot on of its economy. Sorry, a lot
of its economy is based on um accessing
cheap energy from overseas. Uh
specifically the uh GCC. uh China
imports 40% of its energy needs uh from
the GCC and so if um the GCC were to
stop energy production then the Chinese
economy would be in a lot of trouble and
this would give Trump a lot of um
negotiating leverage over China in the
upcoming talks scheduled for miday and I
and I believe that what's going to
happen is that because the Chinese are
extremely pragmatic and very
businessorientated and I think that um
Trump and China will sign a landmark
deal where China agrees to buy a lot of
energy from North America.
>> You're full of praise for China's role
in trying to get peace in the Middle
East. Uh here's what I don't get. You
were caught filming protest by Chinese
workers famously in 2002 as a freelance
journalist at the time. Uh you were
suspected by the Chinese government of
spying. You were deported from China.
Reporters without borders protested your
deportation at the time. How did you get
back into China? And why is it some of
your critics say you have so little to
say about China's role in all of this
geopolitics? Is it because you're not
allowed to currently?
>> Right. So um when I started as a young
journalist um I was subcontracted by by
PBS to do a documentary on China's WTO
entry. And one major issue about China's
um WTO entry of course is worker rights.
And at this time in China there was a
major restructuring of the stateowned
enterprise system. So I was dispatched
to northeastern China to film a worker
protest. Unfortunately the place was
swimming with um police spies and I was
arrested and [clears throat]
interrogated for two days. I was held in
comment NATO for 48 hours which is the
maximum um um by Chinese law and um I
signed a confession saying that I was a
reporter and working in China illegally
as a reporter and the decision was made
to deport me without charging me with um
any crime and so I was allowed to come
back in the country but I was deported.
Um so that was the story.
>> If they suspected you being a spy how do
they let you back in? China is not known
for being that trusting. [snorts]
>> They suspect me of being a spy, but
after a 48 hour investigation, after um
uh doing a thorough background check on
me, they concluded that I was not a spy
and I I was a journalist. Um um working
to film in a a worker protest.
>> But it wasn't just 2002. In 2017, we
checked, you wrote an op-ed for CNN.com
headlined, "China's media enables
tyranny and corruption." In that piece,
you praised the US media as the world's
free speech defender of last resort. You
said, "In China, power trumps truth."
And China's Communist Party, you said,
maintains its iron grip on power by
controlling what's said in the media and
what's taught in the classroom. Do you
stand by those views from less than a
decade ago?
Um so in 2017 when I was asked by CNN to
write an oped um I did stand by those
views at that time because um like
everyone else in 2016 when Donald Trump
won the election I thought this would be
very bad for uh American democracy
because he was clearly not uh a believer
in free speech. He called the um news
media uh fake news. And so I wrote the
op-ed for American audience saying like
the greatest treasure um the greatest
wealth of America is the first
amendment, the right to speak whatever
you want. And I conscious that that with
China where you're not allowed to say
whatever you want, where you are very
much monitored uh by uh the government.
Um even today I do not have a Chinese
online media presence. I do not say
anything online. I do not talk to
reporters in from China because I'm
conscious that whatever I say online
could be used against me.
>> But hold on. They allow you to be on
this show. They allow you to be on
YouTube. You get past the great firewall
that you criticized in that CNN piece.
How come?
>> Look, the reality is that the best way
to understand my situation in China is
I'm essentially a Martian on Earth
talking to Martians back at home in
Mars. Like I am not part of the Chinese
system. I'm on YouTube, which is blocked
in China. I I
>> How do they allow you to be on YouTube?
This is what I'm not understanding. If
you're blocked in China, why do they
allow you to become You're very
prominent now. You're famous in the
West. I'm sure the Chinese government
has noticed that.
>> Well, most Chinese um will have access
to a VPN device, and that's what I use
in order to um access the internet.
You wrote for CNN that the Chinese
government has built the great firewall
to monitor and control their citizens
pursuit of truth. Um, does China control
what you say? Now,
>> China does not control what I say
because again, I'm not talking to
Chinese people. I'm talking to
Westerners.
>> Hold on. That's that's what most people
would say is China's great benefit. They
might see your critics might say they're
using you as a propagandist to come and
say this stuff about Iran and the US on
behalf of China. That would be what your
critics would say. Look, the reality is
that this is a fair and legitimate
criticism that I've been contemplating
for the past 3, four weeks because, you
know, when I first started this YouTube
channel like two years ago, I was
expecting 5,000 uh viewers who would
have a passion for learning, who would
be as engaged with literature and
geopolitics as I was. And over the past
month, I've blown up across the
internet. And I don't think this is
organic, but but so I wonder if there
are some governments or some entities
that believe that my message should be
amplified. Um it is it is possible I'm a
useful idiot and I suspect that there
are many entities around the world who
would like to amplify my message
including the Chinese government also
including the Russian government,
including some aspects of the American
government, including um some some some
people who are hostile towards war. I
appreciate your cander. You said you
blew up on the internet. Uh you did go
viral over your Iran predictions, but on
your YouTube page, as people now start
to acquaint themselves with you and
familiarize with your work, uh people
have been slightly surprised to see some
of your other stuff. You have a series
of lectures focused on secret societies
where you argue that groups like the
Illuminati, the Freemasons, the Jesuits
are at the center of world control.
People would say you sound kind of crazy
when you talk about the Illuminati. It's
the kind of thing you hear in Dan Brown
novels, [clears throat]
>> right? So, I'm trying a new approach to
pedagogy and to scholarship which is
speculative uh which is speculative
analysis. So, um I went to Yale and I
received a very rigorous classical
education. I'm very happy and proud that
I went to Yale. But what I discovered in
life um as I stumbled through life is
that what I what I was taught at Yale
doesn't really apply to uh real life.
People with the most rational, logical
arguments don't usually win. And people
who are the most progressive, most
enlightened aren't usually the ones in
power. So I was determined uh just for
my own personal benefit to develop a new
system which would give me better
insight into how power works in the
world. And so I started um something
called predictive history. And the very
idea of predictive history is this. How
do we know if our understanding of
history is correct? And the answer is
well, we can make predictions based on
on our historical framework. and using
and seeing if these predictions work out
or not uh validate our historical
models. So what I've discovered is that
if you have a combination of game theory
um historical patterning and esquetology
then this gives you a pretty deep
insight into how the world will turn out
and secret societies are very much an
important aspect of esquetology.
>> I'll come back to secret societies a
couple of things you mentioned there. Uh
you said uh you were at Yale. Uh, just
to be clear, your degree was in English
literature, was it not at Yale? It
wasn't in international relations or
national security. You're an English lit
graduate. And you're not a professor. I
know it's your YouTube Monica, but
you're a high school teacher. You're not
actually a professor, [clears throat]
>> right? So, um, when I went to Yale, I
was actually a math and physics major. I
was declared a math and physics major,
but the English department was very
strong, and so I switched majors. Uh, so
I both I have actually both a math
background as well as an English
background. Uh that's why my uh system
of analysis can can seem strange to
people because because I'm combining a
multi-disiplinary approach to my
thinking. Um yeah, and I'm not a
professor. I'm not professor. But but I
never said I was professor. It's the
internet who called me.
>> Hold on. Hold on. You don't call
yourself Professor Gang on your YouTube
channel.
>> I do now. But when I first started out,
if you go way back to my early
>> Doesn't matter. When you first started
out, you do call yourself Professor Jang
and you're not a professor. Look, look,
there's a guy on the internet who call
who calls himself the god. Have you
interviewed him yet? Um, and ask him why
he calls himself the god.
>> I think I I I'm good friends with a
radio host called Charlemagne the god,
but no one actually thinks he's a god.
People actually think you're a
professor. Just sticking with your
analysis. You just said speculative
analysis. To many people, that sounds
like you're just making it up. You're
speculating.
Look, I I think that the problem with
education is that it focuses too much on
facts, too much on rigor, and not enough
on facts. Do you hear yourself? It
sounds you I mean, what do you mean too
much on facts?
>> Look, look, I I I know this sounds
strange, but there is a difference
between facts and truth, right? Facts
are what can be independently verified
by other sources. Truth is a deep
understanding of the world that allows
you to understand why things are the way
they are as well as well as make certain
predictions. We used to be a people, a
human species that was very focused on
truth seeking uh and and that's why
religion was so such an important part
of our lives because um God um prayer
was was very important to help us
understand um our place in the world uh
where we came from, what we're doing
here and where we're going. And now we
just focus on facts on making sure that
you you can memorize the all the
elements of the periodic table on um
making sure that
>> when you talk about when you talk about
secret societies I guess people want to
say well where's the factual evidence
where's the evidence you said I think
the Jesuits control the Vatican first of
all there's nothing wrong with Jesuits
good people I know many of them second
of all there's only ever been one pope
who's a Jesuit and he's gone so people
would wonder like facts are important to
your evidence and people would say that
it's not just fun and games when you're
doing speculation on YouTube uh they
look at some of your rhetoric and they
see that you don't just criticize
Zionism or Israel as many people
legitimately do. You talk about this
pretty far-right concept of Pax
Judeaica, a new world order centered
around Israel. Uh you have a video
called Dawn of the Jews in which you
seek to answer the question, why is it
that Jews are so dominant? Surely you
understand why a lot of people think at
best you're trafficking in pretty
anti-semitic tropes and at worst you're
a card carrying anti-semite when they
see that stuff.
>> Okay. Well, that is a very strong
accusation. So, can you please tell me
uh what specifically I've said that you
find offensive?
>> When you do a video called Dawn of the
Jews, why is it that Jews are so
dominant? You don't find that offensive?
>> I never said Jews were dominant. I what
I said in my lecture was that the Jewish
identity was created by the Persian
Empire in order to better control the
Lavant. And if you read the Bible,
that's exactly what what you can derive
from it. If you go to my lecture on the
Jews, you will see that I use the Bible
as my primary source and then I analyze
what the Bible is saying. The the
problem is that most people don't read
the Bible.
>> But people who came up with Pax Judea
are not biblical scholars. They're the
modern white supremacist farright.
>> Sorry. Sorry. What is wrong with the
term Pax Judea?
>> You tell me. What does it mean? It just
means that um this that um there is an
entity in the Middle East um Israel that
is able to dominate the Middle East very
much along the lines of Pax Americana um
and Pax Britannica and Pax Israel. You
said PAX Judeica that implies all Jews.
You know the tropes about Jews running
the world. I wouldn't be okay if you
said Iran is dominant, Saudi Arabia is
indomant.
In fact, you know that there are many
racists in the west who do believe that
Islam and Muslims are trying to take
over the world. I find that equally
offensive.
>> Right? So, um, so I'm using a Latin
convention and so the Latin convention
would be Pax Judea. It would not be Pax
is I mean it I mean like
>> but you know where this concept comes
from? It exists in farright online
circles. It's not some academic term.
>> Do you believe that the Greater Israel
Project is a farright conspiracy theory?
>> No.
>> What is it then? I think it's a very
real project being carried out by the
Israeli government. I just don't call it
Pax Judea.
>> Right? Okay. So, the difference between
the greater Israel project and Pax
Judeica is this. Greater Israel project
is what uh the Israelites believe that
Yahweh their God promised to their
ancestor Abraham in the Bible. And this
extends from the um uh now to the
Euphrates. And I could have just used
greater Israel project but I want to
differentiate uh because I believe that
Pax Judea is not an empire run by Jews
for Jews by Jews. It is an empire run by
transnational capital and secret
societies in order to create an AI
surveillance state throughout the the
Middle East. Actually listen
>> just to be clear and this is speculative
analysis. This is not based on facts as
you say.
>> So it is it is based on speculative
analysis based on history historical
patterns. It's also based on connect
connecting the dots because if you just
look at what Netanyahu says if you
actually just go and watch on YouTube
>> I know what Netanyahu says. We're in
agreement on how bad Netanyahu is, how
expansionist is. I'm talking about the
language you use, the millure you're in.
Let me ask you this before we wrap up.
What are your own politics? Where do you
place yourself on the political
spectrum?
>> I believe I've always been on the left.
Um um so I I believe that wealth
redistribution is very important. I
believe in freedom of speech. I I am
anti-war. I'm anti-empire. I believe in
individual autonomy. Um and so
unfortunately, I used to be left, but I
think that like given my uh preferences,
given my politics, I believe most people
would consider me on the far right
nowadays. And that's unfortunate.
>> That is unfortunate. Last question. Uh
you made three very famous predictions
in 2024. What is your big prediction now
for 2026? We'll see what happens. We can
test it out at the end of the year.
Well, I've made three predictions about
how this war will progress. Okay. So, my
first prediction is that the United
States will use ground troops and I'm
with you and and and I believe that this
ground troops will be a quagmire for the
United States and that they will have to
call a national draft. Okay, that's my
first prediction. Okay.
>> My second prediction and this is very
important is that
>> Israel and the United States will not
use a nuclear weapon in this war. I
think that the talk of nuclear weapons
is fear-mongering. I don't think we will
escalate to that point of nuclear
weapons.
>> I hope you're right. I worry about
nukes. I hope you're right.
>> And my third and most controversial
prediction is that I believe that during
the course of this war, somehow someway,
uh, the Alexic Moss will be destroyed.
>> Wow.
>> Um, yeah.
>> Well, that would be a disaster. Um, God
forbid. Uh, we will have to leave it
there on that rather dark prediction.
Uh, Shu Chin Jiang, I appreciate you
taking time out. I appreciate you taking
my questions. Thank you so much.
>> Thank you.